NARRATOR: On March 26, 2018
a passenger train leaves
Pyongyang, North Korea.
21 bullet proof cars
painted an olive drab lumber
across the countryside,
then over the Chinese border.
Rumors begin throughout
the international community.
This is the official train
of the North Korea leadership.
Also used by
Kim Il-Sung and Kim Jong-Il,
the grandfather and father of
current leader, Kim Jong-Un.
No one outside of
the notoriously secretive
nation knows who is aboard.
Some speculate it is Kim
Yo-Jong, Un's younger sister
and most trusted advisor.
It is not until the
train reaches its final
destination, Beijing,
that it's revealed
Kim Jong-Un, the
34-year-old dictator himself,
is the passenger.
In the months
preceding this meeting...
What follows in Beijing...
And in the months to come...
Are the preliminary steps
to what may be the most
important diplomatic
event of our young century.
A path to peace on the
Korean peninsula and a way
to bring the North Koreans
into the international fold
after 70 years of isolation.
But the path to peace will be
one of twists and turns as
allies and the US
jockey for position to
protect their interests
and maintain security.
By the time President
Donald Trump and Chairman
Kim Jong-Un meet face to face
in Singapore, it is
still unclear what each party
wants or will be willing to do.
This is the Great Game.
♪ ♪
North Korea
remains an enigma.
-Good Morning, how are you,
Mr. Vice President?
Very nice to see you.
NARRATOR: And only
those who have sat
across the table with
North Korean negotiators
understand the challenges.
RICHARDSON: I do believe
that they're very tough,
they're very well prepared.
They read everything,
especially media.
What makes them so tough,
it's not just their culture,
but the fact that
they've been isolated.
They've been sanctioned.
They hardly any of
them, the citizens,
leave North Korea.
They have television that's
programmed every evening,
for three hours
the government tells you
what you're going to see.
And inevitably,
they hate the United States.
HILL: At the end of the day,
diplomacy is really trying
to get the other
side to do something they
don't really want to do.
in dealing with another
country, make it clear that
you make the hard choices
today and I'm not promising
you the end of hard choices,
but I'm promising you
that in the future you won't
have to make them alone.
ALBRIGHT: Mostly, I
don't see it as a gift.
You usually use diplomacy
more with your adversaries
than with your friends.
And so it is this matter
of being prepared and
putting yourself into the other
country's shoes and figuring
out what you do in order
to solve the problem,
and it's not a gift.
It is how you talk to
those you disagree with.
NARRATOR: The Democratic
People's Republic of Korea,
DPRK,
is anything but democratic.
From the ashes
of World War II,
loomed the first post-war
spread of Soviet communism.
In August 1945, the Korean
peninsula and her people were
effectively divided
at the 38th parallel.
An arbitrary divide.
Using a National Geographic
map, the future US
Secretary of state,
Dean Rusk
and fellow army staffer
Col. Charles "Tic" Bonesteel
knew the decision of the 38th
parallel made no economic or
geographic sense, but
with the cold war about
to cast a long shadow,
the United States wanted Seoul
and the democratic leaning
south, under their alliance.
Kim Il-Sung, the young
charismatic rebel famous for
his insurrection against the
brutal decades old
Japanese occupation,
vied for power and
shaped this new republic in
the Stalinist fashion
adopting a totalitarian
reign of terror.
Kim solidified his place in
the soviet backed north, then
sought to unify the peninsula
by invading the south
and starting the Korean
conflict on June 25th, 1950.
Reporter (over TV): In an
era of renewed optimism.
NARRATOR: Three years
later a cease-fire was reached.
North Korea, a
nation established by warfare,
will be perpetuated
by self-imposed
isolation, bloodshed,
and humanitarian horrors.
TERRY: It's the most
unique country in the world.
What other country
in the world is Confucian,
communist, hereditary, dynasty,
there's no
country like this.
While it also commits
human rights violations.
United Nations Commission
of Inquiries said,
"there's no other parallel
in contemporary history,
except Nazi, Germany"
and this is North Korea.
I don't think there is
another country that is more
isolated than North Korea,
so truly a unique place.
NARRATOR: And they have
been challenging American
policy, for nearly 70 years.
HILL: I think any
political question has
to start with a map.
And if you look at a
map of Northeast Asia,
it's a pretty compact area.
You're seeing Russian
far east interest right there.
You're seeing
Japan right there.
China, enormous interest
right there, South Korea.
And then, in
the middle of this,
you have this funny little
thing called North Korea.
How does it affect
the countries around
it and I would say,
it affects them all big time.
TERRY: North Korea
has figured out how to
work the United States.
There is usually a provocation
of some sort, whether it is
a missile test or a nuke test.
Then there is international
condemnation that follows,
and then they sort of up
the ante, like a poker game.
"Oh yeah? Here's more!"
Then, sort of a
collective "Oh no!"
And then they
step back and say, "OK.
Here is what we can do."
They have some sort of charm
offensive, peace offensive.
Then we meet with them,
we negotiate, we give
them aids, some rewards,
some time passes, then
back to provocation.
It's a provoke
and get paid cycle.
NARRATOR: For generations,
the North Korean
people have been controlled
by a police state that has
perfected propaganda to an art.
Their belief in
the Kim family dynasty,
is absolute devotion.
Information is tightly
controlled by the Korean
central news agency,
the KCNA, established in 1946.
KRISTOF: There've
obviously been many
other deeply repressive
Communist dictators,
Stalin, Mao.
They didn't have
the technology that
the Kim family had.
They didn't have the degree
of social control, so they
didn't have speakers on every,
in every village, speakers
in the wall of every
home to control people.
They didn't have
television in every home.
They didn't even have
these portraits of the leaders
it's kind of a religious cult.
RICHARDSON: It's the deity,
it's the leaders, the
grandfather, the father,
and now Kim Jong-Un,
that are not just
political figures, they're
god like religious figures.
And what they say determines
how North Koreans act.
GAUSE: Kim Jong-Un only had a
very short amount of time to
build his legitimacy
within the regime.
Kim Jong-Il by comparison
had 30 years to create
his legitimacy.
Kim Jong-Un had none of this,
but a lot of things, very
interesting things began to
happen when Kim Jong-Un
came to power.
The first thing
that happened is they
had the missile test,
which was a failure.
But what does North Korea do?
They admit it was a
failure, unprecedented.
Why did they do that?
It gave people pause
to think that maybe this
was something different.
Kim Jong-Un laid down the
Rosetta Stone of where he
wanted to take this regime.
People would no longer
have to tighten their belts,
this was an important
statement by Kim Jong-Un.
There was no mention
whatsoever of the nuclear
program in that speech because
that's not where Kim
Jong-Un wanted his legacy.
That was Kim Jong-Il's legacy
was the nuclear program.
His legacy was to
create the strong
and prosperous nation.
HILL: He then created
a kind of chaotic situation
within the worker's party,
the North Korean Workers'
Party and actually had
his uncle Jang Song-Thaek
perp-walked out of a party
meeting and killed the next day.
So, Kim Jong-Un began a series
of executions of senior
North Korean figures
such that it was hard to find
a common denominator of why
these people had been executed.
But certainly, one can
speculate that he didn't feel
they were sufficiently
loyal to him.
NARRATOR: He purges over
400 senior military and
ministry leaders publicly.
And allegedly has his
older half-brother murdered
in a Malaysian airport,
poisoned by
unwitting assassins.
But he needs something else
to secure the Kim dynasty,
nuclear weapons that could
pose a real and present
danger to America
and her Asian allies.
GAUSE: This would be
the launching of the
the Kim Jong-Un era.
He had to show legitimacy.
And if he couldn't
show legitimacy on
the economic realm,
he had to show legitimacy
in the security realm.
And so he began to move very
quickly towards developing
the nuclear program so that he
would have something
to hang his hat on.
So, it will give him a much
stronger position in which
to negotiate with
the United States.
NARRATOR: Kim Jong-Il
moved the nuclear program
forward in spite of
international
outcry and on again
off again treaties.
Now it is his son
who may finish the job,
having a strong hand to
negotiate a way for his
impoverished nation
to have an economic revival.
ALBRIGHT: I think that he
does have a good hand to play.
I mean, he has in fact, from
his perspective, developed a
nuclear potential and missiles
to do the delivery on it,
and he's managed to scare
the whole region
into doing something.
NARRATOR: Through 2016
to mid-September, 2017,
Kim Jong-Un
conducts three nuclear tests,
including a hydrogen bomb,
and 30 short and long-range
missile launches;
including Intercontinental
Ballistic Missiles.
Kim claims that
they have nuclear warheads
small enough to
fit on each ICBM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: In
70 years, in times
of war and peace...
NARRATOR: In September 2017
president Donald Trump
addresses the
UN General Assembly.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: No one
has shown more contempt
for other nations,
and for the well-being of
their people than the depraved
regime in North Korea.
NARRATOR: He delivers
a fiery speech
attacking Kim Jong-Un
and threatening the
destruction of his country.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: Rocket man
is on a suicide mission for
himself, and for his regime...
NARRATOR: Trump's rhetoric
feeds directly into the
north's propaganda machine,
that America wants to
annihilate North Korea.
TERRY: I think that was
definitely off script, I
can't impossibly imagine
the administration
officials like Mattis
or Secretary Tillerson,
advocating totally
destroying North Korea,
I just can't
possibly fathom that,
so I think that was
President Trump speaking.
KRISTOF: I think North
Korean officials have played
a weak hand just brilliantly.
While I think the US approach
has to some degree backfired.
Essentially the US was trying
to intimidate North Korea
with some of this rhetoric
about fire and fury,
about complete destruction.
And I think what we actually
accomplished was that we
terrified South Korea into
engaging in diplomacy
with North Korea.
ALBRIGHT: I think that it's
very hard to really assess
what effect President Trump's
language had on Kim Jong-Un.
I don't know whether it
scared the Japanese, too.
NARRATOR: The United Nations
Security Council votes
for maximum pressure through
economic sanctions
against the north.
HALEY: We have kicked the
can down the road long enough.
There is no more road left.
NARRATOR: A war of words
between Pyongyang and
President Trump begins.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: North Korea
bess not make any more threats
to the United States.
NARRATOR: Kim
refers to Trump as a
"mentally deranged dotard."
Trump insists his red
button is bigger than Kim's.
Still the DPRK tests another
ICBM, this one experts agree,
has a range that could hit
the continental United States.
The US Talked openly
about a "bloody nose"
military strike that would
cripple nuclear testing sites.
Only a handful of
experts believed this
was a viable solution.
KRISTOF: Diplomacy is a
hugely inefficient toolbox.
It doesn't work very well.
But in cases like
North Korea, it's all we
have to resolve this crisis.
Ever since 1969,
when North Korea shot
down a US aircraft
and killed a bunch of Americans,
the US has looked
for ways to shape
North Korean behavior.
So repeatedly you have
very smart officials who,
when they're out of power,
they talk about
military options.
And then once in power, and
they look at the predictions
of perhaps a million-people
dying on the very first day
of a war with North Korea,
then they think well,
okay maybe this
isn't the best option.
And they look at what's left.
And what's left is diplomacy.
NARRATOR: Adding to
the growing anxiety
on the peninsula,
south Korea was preparing
the 2018 Olympic games.
And there was precedent
to feel insecure; thirty
years earlier in 1988,
South Korea's first
Olympics were being planned.
The supreme leader,
Kim Il-Sung set out
to create a chaotic
atmosphere to keep
people away from the games.
JENNINGS (over TV):
Investigators now
believe that a bomb,
possibly planted by
2 passengers may have
caused Sunday's crash
of a Korean Airliner.
TERRY: They downed a
civilian airliner, killed
115 people on board,
it was a major terror attack.
That was the reason why the
United States put North Korea
on the states
sponsor of terror list,
and it also shows you just
the brutality and just
the insanity because they
downed a civilian airliner
killing 115 people
on board just to disrupt
the Olympics
that was going to
be held in South Korea.
NARRATOR: The DPRK was
banned from competition.
But the games went on,
a huge coming out party,
a turning point for Seoul
as it pulled further away
from the north politically,
economically
and culturally.
It only fueled the rivalry
between the two Koreas.
Then, on New Years Day 2018,
Kim Jong-Un gives a speech
as tensions on
the Korean peninsula
reach a searing point.
HILL: At first, I think
there was a considerable or a
preponderance of views to the
effect that this is
all an effort to create
wedges between the
United States and South Korea.
It's also an effort really,
to show South Korea that
North Korea can be a good
neighbor even if it has
nuclear weapons.
NARRATOR: This "olive branch"
was heard around the world.
-The IOC has approved...
NARRATOR: Moon Jae-in
invites the north to
march together at the games.
ALBRIGHT: I can
understand what President
Moon is trying to do, now,
in terms of they are living
there in this very dangerous
area, and these issues,
and they're much more
complicated than just
one issue like missiles.
It's their way of life.
NARRATOR: The North Korean
delegation arrived at the
Olympic games lead by
Kim's younger sister and
closest confident, Kim Yo-Jong.
Her presence captivated
the South Koreans,
part curiosity, part relief
that she appeared so
poised and confident.
TERRY: North Koreans
won on that whole image
makeover contest.
Kim Yo-Jong was called Ivanka
of the Kim administration,
she was hugely popular
in South Korea,
she seemed human,
she seemed normal,
she was charming,
she was smiling.
PENCE: We'll be telling
the truth about
North Korea at every stop.
NARRATOR: The
American delegation, led
by Vice President Pence
held talks with
North Korean defectors,
implored the south to ignore
overtures from the north,
met with the family
of Otto Warmbier,
the University of Virginia
student who died soon
after being released from a
North Korean prison in a coma,
and avoided
a state dinner so not be
with the DPRK delegation.
During the opening ceremonies
the body language could not
be more evident as
Pence sat stone faced.
TERRY: Then when the
joint team walked in.
It's not only
North Korean Olympians,
there were South Korean
Olympians that were walking in.
You can stand up,
you can stand up and cheer
because this is your ally,
South Korea is hosting
the Olympics and you're seeing
the South Korean athletes also
coming in, with
North Korean athletes,
so you should stand up
and be welcoming.
I didn't think we
scored any kind of
points on that image front.
NARRATOR: It's on this visit
that Kim Yo-Jong hand delivers
a letter from her brother,
inviting President Moon
to meet him in person.
Washington watches.
ALBRIGHT: President Moon
is somebody that is regarded
more as a liberal within their
system, had come forward with
the idea that there needed
to be more cooperation.
I also do think
that there are those who
believe in the
crazy man theory that
some of the threats that
President Trump made
I think it's conceivable
had some role in changing the
mind of the North Koreans,
but I think the question is:
What happens next?
NARRATOR: Both Washington and
Seoul agree to keep up the
diplomatic momentum
that began since the new year.
And president Moon
Jae-in sends a ten-member
delegation to Pyongyang.
Kim Jong-Un calls the
four-hour meeting an
"open hearted talk...
actively improving the
north-south relations and
ensuring peace and stability
on the Korean peninsula."
Washington remains skeptical
saying that the south should
not normalize relations with
the north without discussion
of denuclearization.
-We remained determined to
achieve a denuclearization of
the Korean peninsula.
NARRATOR: But President Moon,
like a matchmaker, persuades
the north and the US
to soften their positions,
insisting that the two
initiatives move in parallel,
urging the US to start
talks with the DPRK.
Kim Jong-Un says he will
put denuclearization of
the peninsula on the table.
And three days later
Moon's diplomats are
at the White House
carrying a letter
from chairman Kim.
NARRATOR: The first time
a sitting American president
will meet face to face with a
leader of North Korea.
PRESIDENT TRUMP:
Of the Korean Peninsula...
NARRATOR: Many in the
diplomatic community are
surprised, and concerned.
An unconventional president
meeting an unpredictable
dictator, as equals.
A president known more
for behaving on instinct
than precedent who shuns
preparation or study, speaking
directly with a famously
thinned skinned impulsive
dictator, all while the
White House is embroiled
in multiple scandals,
a growing global trade war,
and the US State Department
and national security team
are in flux.
Secretary of state
Rex Tillerson is
soon fired by Trump.
National security
advisor HR McMaster
resigns afterward.
ALBRIGHT: The issue is
how prepared President
Trump will be for it.
Usually, a summit meeting
takes place towards the end
of negotiations where the
President can then come in
and put the last stone in,
and really add
some piece to it,
but not having done the
building of the whole thing.
And so, it will take
incredible discipline.
HILL: If it fails, if one
of them walks out on a huff,
if one of them suggests,
"No. We can't do this,"
then, where are
you going to go?
Because you've already put in
your closer and your closer,
your leader should be able
to kind of nail down the last
two issues that are out there.
Instead, you have your
leaders starting the process.
RICHARDSON: I think
they're both very much
alike, they're autocratic,
they're unpredictable.
and, uh, it could come out a
decent outcome but we're unsure.
And I've said to the Trump
administration, the gamble
of talking to Kim Jong-Un
is a huge gamble, but
I think it's the right
gamble, but be prepared.
They're relentless.
If we're not prepared, we
don't have our act together,
we put up unrealistic
expectations, they're
going to outsmart us.
NARRATOR: The wheels are
literally in motion.
RICHARDSON: I've seen
that train, nobody else
could ride in that train.
the good news is that
he's starting to talk
to other leaders.
NARRATOR: It's March 27, 2018.
Kim has not traveled
outside of the DPRK since
he assumed power in 2011.
And he has yet to meet
with another head of state.
RICHARDSON: They're going
to China to ask for something
and that's diplomacy,
you get squeezed,
you do something.
And this is irrational
actor, Kim Jong-Un,
taking these steps.
I believe, I'm not sure,
I'm not there but this is
what he's probably doing.
NARRATOR: One month before
he meets with Moon, chairman
Kim in a surprise move,
arrives in Beijing to
meet president Xi Jinping
for the first time.
TERRY: I think he was doing a
couple things, I think he was
trying to get some sort of
sanctions relieved, some
sort of to see where
China is in all of that.
Assure China that China's
interests would be protected,
but I think he also took an
opportunity to sort of
showcase himself as a leader.
I think he really used it
to normalize his image, as
a normal leader of a normal
country, a modern leader
of a modern nation, here
he brought his very young,
attractive wife and other
senior North Korean officials,
spent four days
with President Xi.
There's President Xi,
his wife, Kim Jong-Un
and his attractive wife,
drinking, laughing, talking.
So a great image makeover
for Kim, and I think it was
very smart to have done that.
NARRATOR: Japanese
prime minister Shinzo Abe
meets with Trump to
assure Japan's
interests are not in peril.
And President Trump
confirms that then
CIA chief, Mike Pompeo,
met secretly
with Kim Jong-Un two weeks
earlier, on Easter weekend,
beginning
the planning process of
the Trump-Kim summit.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: And he just
left North Korea, had a great
meeting with Kim Jong-Un,
got along with him
really well, really great.
NARRATOR: Pompeo is poised
to become Secretary of State.
And hard liner, former
UN ambassador John Bolton,
is appointed National
Security Advisor.
One week before Kim Jong-Un
and Moon Jae-In meet,
North Korea declares
it will halt all nuclear
and long-range missile tests.
And as Kim shifts national
focus to the north's economy,
he says he will shutdown
one of his nuclear test sites.
President Trump tweets,
"This is very good news for
North Korea and the world,
big progress."
Now on the table is
the denuclearization of
the Korean peninsula,
and discussion of a peace
treaty, officially ending the
Korean war which concluded
with only an armistice,
ceasing seventy
years of hostility.
NARRATOR: The Panmunjom truce
village traverses both North
and South Korea inside the
Demilitarized Zone
along the 38th parallel.
Here President Moon
and chairman Kim meet
for the first time
on April 27th, 2018.
Kim becomes the first
North Korean leader to ever
to set foot in the south.
The optics show
a warm and congenial
burgeoning relationship.
TERRY: Well it was
really interesting to
watch Kim Jong-Un in terms of
body language, his voice,
how he was handling himself.
He's nothing like his father,
who actually was a very big
introvert, and was not social.
He looked like Kim II-Sung
to me, his grandfather.
He was warm, he was effusive,
he was touchy-feely.
He was affectionate, he
laughed whole-heartedly.
So, he came across as
actually a charming person,
a social person who can
engage with people,
laughing and joking.
So, all of that
was very interesting to
me, as a Korea watcher.
NARRATOR: The day long
summit ends with a pledge to
formally end the Korean war
and a declaration
to denuclearize
the Korean peninsula.
Another date is set to start
negotiations in mid-May.
But fast-moving events in
the coming months begin to
raise the stakes of whether
a summit with Kim and
Trump will even happen.
The next day Trump holds
a campaign-style rally in
Macomb County, Michigan.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: So we
are doing very well.
I spoke to the
president this morning of
South Korea for a long time.
They just had a
very good meeting.
He gives us tremendous credit.
He gives us all the credit.
I had one of the fake news
groups this morning...
(crowd boo's).
They were saying, "What do
you think President Trump
had to do with it?"
I'll tell you what,
like how about everything?
NARRATOR: Once the South
Koreans thought of Donald Trump
as much of a
danger as Kim Jong-Un.
But now for months, they have
been thanking Trump for making
the start of a
reconciliation possible,
some believe it's to
appeal to his ego and maintain
the momentum of the talks.
President Moon tells
his senior secretaries,
"President Trump should
win the Nobel Peace Prize.
What we need is only peace."
ALBRIGHT: There are a
lot of leaders who I
think are playing Trump in
terms of understanding that
if they flatter him, that
they make an impression.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: The
Nobel Peace prize?
-Yes sir.
-Well I just think
President Moon was very
nice when he suggested it.
I wanna, I wanna get peace.
The main thing,
we wanna get peace.
NARRATOR: North Korean
officials start to take
offense that the president is
taking all the credit to help
bring peace to the region.
They claim the sanctions were
not responsible for Kim coming
to the negotiating table.
And Washington
is "ruining the mood"
leading up to peace talks.
TERRY: It's not all just
US maximum pressure strategy
that led to this point.
I think Kim Jong-Un
himself had a strategy,
he now gets to sit down with
the President of
the United States
for the first time.
So, I think this shows
that Kim Jong-Un is a
different kind of leader.
I think he has shown himself
to be bold and astute
and quite smart, actually.
NARRATOR: Then John Bolton,
the new national security
advisor who favors military
action and regime change
with hostile nations appears
on CBS' Face The Nation.
BRENNAN: But is it
a requirement that Kim Jong-Un
agree to give away those
weapons before you give
any kind of concession?
BOLTON:
I think that's right.
I think we're looking at the
Libya model of 2003, 2004.
We're also looking at what
North Korea itself has
committed to previously.
TERRY: North Koreans love to
use Libya as an example of
why they must keep
nuclear weapons.
They repeatedly say, look
what happened to Gaddafi.
Gaddafi gave up nuclear
weapons, then the West helped
the revolt against Gaddafi,
and now Gaddafi's dead.
So, when North Koreans
hear John Bolton say we're
pursuing a Libyan model,
I think this
is not helpful because
North Koreans are always,
they are afraid of
becoming another Libya.
NARRATOR: Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo
arrives in Pyongyang a second
time to discuss the summit.
This time he returns with
three Americans that were
jailed in North Korea for
crimes against the state.
It's believed to be a
goodwill gesture by Kim.
As the US confers with
anxious allies in the region,
Kim too makes another
surprise trip to Beijing.
TERRY: There's multiple
overlapping interests and
not all of them are aligned.
It's very complicated,
I speculate that Kim Jong-Un
was showing Xi Jinping
what a deal with United States
might look like and what does
China think of it;
because you really
need Chinas buy in.
Meanwhile, our ally
Japan is very unhappy
how things are unfolding
even though they can't
really quite say it.
Because they are so
worried that United States
is going to make a deal with
North Korea that
protects US interests.
South Korea is trying
to be sort of an honest
broker, intermediary,
but is sort of worried
that everything
is going to blow up,
so there's a lot going on with
different countries trying
to seek their own interests.
NARRATOR: Meanwhile,
President Trump fulfills
a campaign promise and
pulls out of the Iran
nuclear deal amid protests
by our European allies.
Many speculate what this
would signal for the upcoming
summit with the DPRK.
HILL: It would be an
interesting point of
conversation, frankly,
if Kim Jong-Un said
to President Trump,
"We've looked at the Iran deal,
and you say it's the worst
deal ever, why do you say it's
the worst deal ever because
I'm not sure we can reach a
deal that's anywhere as good
as the Iran deal from your
perspective, Mr. President."
So, I think the President is
going to have to make some
attitudinal changes
about the Iran deal in a
way that will help if there
is a prospect of
a North Korea deal.
NARRATOR: Wrinkles
begin to appear as
the DPRK starts reading
into statements
coming out of Washington.
RICHARDSON: Diplomacy is not
Twitter or Facebook or press
releases or cable news.
Diplomacy is human beings
talking to each other and
reaching an agreement,
showing respect, showing
respect for culture, letting
the other side save face,
letting the other side
save credit, building
relationships.
That's diplomacy.
NARRATOR: The north releases
a statement rejecting
Bolton's Libya model claim.
Referring to him
as "repugnant," they say they
will never completely disarm.
That combined with a joint
South Korean and American
military exercise along the
border of the north is enough
for the north to cancel the
next inter-Korean talks and
puts the Trump-Kim
summit at risk.
NARRATOR: To save his summit
with Kim, President Trump
begins to back pedal on
Bolton's statement.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: "Well,
the Libyan model isn't a model
that we have at all when we're
thinking of North Korea.
But if we make a deal, I
think Kim Jong-Un is going
to be very, very happy.
I really believe he's
going to be very happy.
But this is just the opposite.
And I think when John Bolton
made that statement, he was
talking about if we're going
to be having a problem,
because we cannot let
that country have nukes,
we just can't do it.
NARRATOR: With three
weeks to the historic summit,
set for June 12th
2018 in Singapore, the
tension once again rises.
And President Moon makes
a trip to Washington in the
hope he can save the talks.
To North Korean experts
this is no surprise.
The idea of Kim giving up his
nuclear arsenal wholesale in
exchange for economic relief,
was always a non-starter,
they want their
own security assured.
HILL: They'll look
for some sort of security
agreement quite possibly,
asking us not to
have any more exercises
with the South Koreans.
Potentially, they
could ask us to remove
troops or potentially,
they could ask us to
reduce our nuclear arsenal.
NARRATOR: After meeting
with Moon, Trump says he can
live with a slower path to
denuclearization, reversing
his earlier demand
for immediate disarmament.
It is now that events
begin at a frantic pace.
The South Korean leadership
predicts a 99.9% chance
of the summit continuing.
But the north picks up
on statements made by
vice president Pence.
PENCE: You know
there was some talk about
the Libya Model last week,
and as the President
made clear,
this will only end
like the Libya Model ended
if Kim Jong-Un
doesn't make a deal.
-Some people saw
that as a threat.
PENCE: Well I
think it's more of a fact.
NARRATOR: The North Koreans
had only harsh words,
calling the vice president
a "political dummy."
and continued, "Whether the
US will meet us at a meeting
room or encounter us at
nuclear-to-nuclear showdown
is entirely dependent
upon the decision... of the US"
GAUSE: The nuclear
program is intimately tied
into two primary objectives
for Kim Jong-Un and the
North Korean regime.
One is the survival
of the regime, and two is the
perpetuation of the Kim family
rule, and the nuclear program
is intimately tied into that.
NARRATOR: The next morning,
Trump blindsides the two
Koreas and abruptly cancels
the summit expressing
"tremendous anger and open
hostility" on North Korea's
part, but he leaves the
door open to future talks.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I believe
that this is a tremendous
setback for North Korea
and indeed a
setback for the world.
NARRATOR: Two
days later, chairman
Kim and President Moon
meet at the truce village.
They agree to hold
frequent discussions.
As the clock ticks, American
and North Korean officials
hold back channel meetings.
The north openly states
they are willing to
continue with the summit.
President Trump thanks
chairman Kim for a solid
response to his letter and
says the White House
is preparing for
talks on June 12th.
President Trump tweets,
"We have put a great
team together for our
talks with North Korea.
Meetings are
currently taking place
concerning summit and more."
ALBRIGHT: There is no
way to describe to anybody
how long it takes to have
these kind of talks,
and how much preparation
has to come from it.
Also, what the relationship
is with the allied countries.
NARRATOR: Now, an event
that would normally
take months or years
to arrange is
happening in days.
Mike Pompeo meets in
New York City to discuss the
path to denuclearization with
Vice Chairman Kim Yong-Choi,
the DPRKs top
nuclear negotiator.
And in Pyongyang Kim meets
with Russia's foreign minister
with an invitation
to come to Moscow.
Raising concerns
with the White House.
President Trump tweets,
"Our United States team
has arrived in North Korea
to make arrangements
for the summit
between Kim Jong Un and myself.
I truely believe North Korea
has brilliant potential."
KRISTOF: It has been
incredibly frustrating, and
North Korea has lied to us.
Has cheated us.
We indeed have likewise
not fulfilled some of our
obligations to North Korea.
But the last best
hope of trying to resolve
some of these issues
is going to be to
rely on diplomacy.
There's no other way,
there's no alternative to try
to resolve this crisis except
to try to
negotiate a better one.
NARRATOR: After talks
with Pompeo, Kim Yong-Choi
arrives at the White House
carrying a letter
from Kim Jong-Un,
the first time
a North Korean dignitary
visited there since 2000.
After two hours,
President Trump and
Vice Chairman Kim Yong-Choi
emerge from the White House.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: You people
are going to have to travel
because you'll be in Singapore
on June 12th and I think
it will be a process.
I never said it goes in
one meeting, I think it's
going to be a process.
But the relationships
are building and that's
a very positive thing.
NARRATOR: Two weeks later,
after a bruising G-7 summit,
Trump is accused of further
alienating traditional allies.
He leaves for Singapore
confident that he can forge a
new relationship with a
traditional adversary;
insisting he doesn't
need a lot of preparation.
HILL: The whole
concern about the summit
was the idea that they were
essentially going to do it
with very little preparation.
And the president was
going to trust his instincts.
That's one problem.
The second problem
is that sometimes his
instincts are wrong.
And so that's where you need
to have a lot of preparation.
They essentially went in with
very little preparation and
they certainly didn't have an
agreement on the overall
issue of denuclearization
except that North Korea said
they're in favor of it.
NARRATOR: In Singapore,
a media frenzy begins as
over 2500 reporters gather.
Chairman Kim arrives aboard
a Chinese state airliner.
Some say it's a
message from Xi Jinping
that the DPRK is his vassal,
tread lightly.
The prime minister of
Singapore meets with Kim,
and everywhere he travels
he's treated with
rock star status.
An international
pariah now looked upon as a
statesman who may bring peace
to a nervous region.
President Trump
arrives on Air Force One.
After a state lunch he remains
in his hotel for the night.
POMPEO: The president is
fully prepared for the
meeting tomorrow.
I have personally had the
opportunity to make sure that
he has had the chance to hear
lots of different voices,
all of the intended
opportunities and risks and
that we have put these two
leaders in the right place.
NARRATOR: In stark contrast,
Kim seemingly
relishes the attention as he
tours the streets of the city.
Next morning, June 12th,
the flag draped stage
is set for the historic
handshake as the two leaders
meet at 9:04 am
for the first time.
They will speak one on
one with only interpreters
in the room for 45 minutes.
HILL: Probably the thing
I worried about the most
was when he was going in
one on one because
he's not terribly well rooted
in some of the issues and
I thought he might get spun
around on that.
And we still don't
know what he agreed to.
NARRATOR: After a
working lunch, the
two emerge to address an
anxious global community.
NARRATOR: The analysis
is that though the
meeting was historic,
the details of the
agreement were vague at best.
Trump spent much time
flattering Kim, elevated
him to status of an equal,
and in a move that
blindsided South Korea,
Japan, and the Pentagon,
Trump agreed to halt US
led military exercises on
the peninsula potentially
weakening any
military response.
HILL: What was signed
was an Agreed Statement,
but when you read the text of
the Agreed Statement
there's a lot less there
that meets the eye,
certainly less than
was agreed back in 2005.
I think they'll need another
statement or better yet ignore
what was done in Singapore and
just start building something
as the Secretary of State
begins the very
necessary diplomacy.
NARRATOR: The hard
work of keeping the
north engaged begins.
And it could draw out
well beyond the Trump
administration date of 2020.
But for now, the threat
of war has been hushed.
HILL: This problem
is not going to be
solved with just the
US and North Korea.
We need to be talking to the
Chinese, we need to be talking
to the South Koreans and
of course we need
to be talking to
the Japanese as well.
Captioned by Cotter
Captioning Services.